here is the United Nations Secretary
General I believe this is yesterday and
yes he wants to make sure that they
crack down on you
we'll call for Action from everyone with
influence on the spread of me and this
information on the internet
governments Regulators policy makers
technology companies the media Civil
Society
stop the hate
set up strong guard rails be accountable
for language that causes harm
and as part of my report or common
agenda we are convening all stakeholders
around the code of conduct for
information Integrity on digital
platforms
and we'll also further strengthen our
focus on our means and disinformation
are impacting progress on global issues
including the climate crisis
if we had a president who was competent
or remotely pro-america or something
like that I would be a hundred percent a
hundred percent for the president of the
United States to first off kick the
United Nations out of New York City
right we're footing the bill on a whole
bunch of this stuff and there's always
these stories every year about how none
of the ambassadors or any of the people
from other countries they don't pay
their parking tickets in New York City
right just as one little small example
of the negligence of these people but I
would have no problem kicking that guy
out of the country that we foot the bill
to have this crazy giant building where
you run rampant with your anti-western
anti-free speech uh anti-anti decent
Society nonsense where the Human Rights
Commission is usually run by Syria and
Lebanon and you get up there in a place
that that defends Free Speech a country
that is the beacon of free speech in the
entire world and you dare get up there
in what was once a great City not So
Much Anymore New York City and you talk
about how you're going to pressure
governments to step down and clamp down
on free speech that you want more guard
rails you want to watch out for language
well sorry tough guy we've got the first
amendment in the United States and it's
backed up by the Second Amendment and uh
you ain't gonna do it here with the
first amendment is still the jealousy
world over there are many other
countries that unfortunately will abide
by these globalist dictates because they
don't have it's not baked into their
founding their founding documents that
you are allowed to say what you think
and what's also interesting is these big
tech companies that he's trying to apply
this pressure on many of them are
American companies so Elon Musk I am
fairly certain is not going to bend to
this guy's will some of them uh Facebook
some of the other ones again they're
still American companies but they might
be more inclined to do that uh Elon Musk
saw that video going around on Twitter
and this is what he responded with the
UN is more likely to cause rather than
prevent disinformation ain't it the
truth so we have some good good people
fighting
[Music]